-Yet more shocking text messages
have emerged
in the investigation of
the January 6th insurrection and
Donald Trump's attempted coup
with the investigation
now implicating
several members of Congress.
Democrats, meanwhile, have spent
the last day
or so chasing
their own tails
over the President's signature
Build Back Better plan.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you're of the mind, as I am,
that the Republican Party
has been captured
by an authoritarian cult
of goons, weirdos,
and asymmetrical crime goblins
who always look like
they just walked in
on their parents having sex
with a different set
of parents...
"Mom, Dad, I thought you hated
the Petrocellis!"
"No, Rudy. Don't let this screw
you up for your whole life!"
And if you agree
that Republicans
pose an existential threat
to democracy
if they ever
get back into power,
then the logical and somewhat
sobering conclusion
of that belief is that our only
hope is the Democratic Party,
which is not
a comforting thought.
It's like being on the outside
of the NFL playoff picture
and needing the Jets to win.
"Okay, guys,
we're in with a win,
a Broncos loss and the Jets win,
so why didn't you pack up
all your lockers
and I'll see you next summer?"
[ Laughter ]
Yesterday, for example,
was quite the roller coaster
of incompetence from Democrats.
They started the day
by announcing
that they were
abandoning their signature
social spending bill,
the Build Back Better plan,
which sounds like the name
of a [bleep] house-flipping show
on HGTV hosted
by a married couple
who can't agree on anything.
"I thought you wanted
an accent wall."
"No, I said
I wanted shiplap."
"Well, I think
you're full of shiplap."
"This is why I cheated on you
with the Property Brothers!
And remember,
they do everything together."
[ Laughter ]
Democrats said they were
shelving their signature
Build Back Better plan
in order to pursue
voting rights legislation,
which is also urgently necessary
but requires changing
the filibuster rules.
Then they claim
they were making progress
on changing those rules,
only to have
Senator Kyrsten Sinema
announced hours later
that she was still against
changing the filibuster
to protect voting rights,
which was then followed up
by Senator Joe Manchin,
the guy who lives on a houseboat
called Almost Heaven,
like he's Captain Ron's
deadbeat dad,
suggesting that
he might still be open
to a price tag of $1.75 trillion
for the Build Back Better plan
and screaming at a reporter
who asked him
about the bill...
All in all, a great day
for the Democratic Party.
Such a grumpy old man move
to say
to someone not just that
they're full of B.S.,
but that they
themselves are [bleep].
He sounds like you
just got in a fight
with a sales associate
at Lowe's who told him
he can't use a coupon
for a Duraflame.
"You're [bleep], Gary,
and I'm taking my business
over to Ace Hardware."
By the way, I want to take
a moment to point out
that we have not rolled
a clip yet,
which is bad news for Wally
because he uses the clips
to take breaks
from holding up the cue cards.
I mean, look at his arms
right now.
[ Laughter ]
Stay strong, Wally!
-Seth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Seth, Seth, please,
please roll a clip.
My physical therapist said
I can't take much more of this.
-Alright. I'll do my best
to get to it.
Manchin's outburst reminds me
of this moment
from a few years back
when the term "fake news"
started to become a thing
and Trump hurled it at a
reporter like a personal insult.
-Can you give us a question?
Can you give us a question?
-I'm not gonna give you
a question.
You are fake news.
[ Laughter ]
-He sounded like a gossipy teen
at a high school locker.
"Becky said that Joanna said
that Tyler said
that Mark said
that you are fake news."
Hey, we rolled the clip.
Are you happy now, Wally?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Seth, never been better, baby.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I'm, uh...
glad you're good, Wally,
because I'm, um,
not doing great.
See, yesterday,
during "A Closer Look,"
I got all tripped up when Wally
held up this card
with the words
"So now we what these."
[ Laughter ]
Made no sense,
so Wally did this,
putting his finger
over the "we,"
which made the sentence
make even less sense.
Wally, do you now understand
that a word was missing
and that that word was "know"?
-Uh, yeah, I do,
but I needed the 'know'
for something else, Seth.
-What did you need
to "know" for?
-For this.
Hey, kids.
Be nice to your cue card guy,
because he can [bleep] you over.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Wally counts
as a series regular now.
[ Laughter ]
Anybody remember
what we're talking about?
Oh, right. Now I do.
Here we go. Keep going.
It turns out Manchin
was calling the reporter [bleep]
because the reporter asked him
about one of the bill's
most important
and transformative policies --
an extension
of the child tax credit
that has helped dramatically
slash child poverty.
If Democrats don't
pass Build Back Better,
the credit will expire.
And on top of that, President
Biden just announced
that he plans to restart federal
student loan payments
in February.
I mean, Democrats,
what's wrong with you?
In a midterm year, you want to
take away cash for children
and make people
pay student loans again?
What's next?
Do we all have to pitch in
for Joe Manchin's
houseboat renovations?
So the Democrats
are in bad shape politically
and seem to be
making things worse
for themselves for no reason,
which is bad because the party
standing in the wings
to retake power are Republicans,
who tried to stage a coup
and remain enthralled
to an aspiring authoritarian.
With Democrats sputtering,
Republicans are hoping inflation
and specifically
rising meat prices
will help them in the midterms.
Recently, the White House
said the blame
for rising meat prices rests
in part with meat conglomerates.
And then Fox News
decided to repeat a term
for those companies
to deride Biden that, well,
let's just say the term
was a little distracting.
-Everything costs too damn much.
First, it was
the pandemic's fault.
Now it's Big Meat.
Corporate greed and Big Meat.
That's what you do
to your rival.
Don't you define your rival --
in this case, Big Meat?
Big Meat is
something people can remember.
-But they're making up
a rival, right?
So, like, Big Meat
is not their rival.
-The guy at the supermarket,
Geraldo, with the little gun,
the price gun,
he shoots it on the meat there,
he gets a note from Big Meat
every week
with the price that the steaks
are going to be.
Big Meats.
-Big Meat.
-Why are they saying
Big Meat so much?
Is this Fox News After Dark?
They sound like they're on
a press tour for a porno
about a pizza delivery guy.
"We had a lot of fun
making 'Big Meat.'
Made tons of on-set pranks."
The worst part of that segment
came when Rudy got confused
and accidentally
Googled Big Meat.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe they're just sticking up
for Big Meat,
because that was Trump's
Secret Service code name.
"Big Meat is coming through.
I repeat,
Big Meat is coming through,
and it looks like he's with
Bacon Bit and Lunchables."
[ Laughter ]
"They call me Lunchables because
I'm always a little wet."
This is a good encapsulation of
Republican politics right now.
It's both very dangerous
and very dumb at the same time,
because when they're not
claiming Democrats
are targeting Big Meat,
Republicans are also defending
Trump's attempted coup
while planning the next one.
In fact, the committee
investigating the coup
keeps unearthing more
shocking revelations.
Last night, we told you
about private texts from Don Jr.
and several Fox News host
during the January 6th attack.
Now we're learning about several
texts from Republican lawmakers
who have so far
remained unnamed.
In one text before January 6th
even took place,
an unnamed GOP lawmaker
suggested truly insane plan
to have swing states
just declare themselves
for Trump
before the results are even in.
-Members of the January 6th
committee
now, just a moment ago,
revealed some more
of the text messages
that he had willingly handed
over to the committee
before stonewalling.
One of the texts
reveals the conversation
to overthrow
the election results
started on November 4th,
a day after the election.
A lawmaker messages Meadows,
"Here's an aggressive strategy.
Why can't the states of Georgia,
North Carolina, and Pennsylvania
and other R-controlled state
houses declare this is B.S.
and just send
their own electors to vote
and have it go back
to the SCOTUS."
-Anytime someone starts a text
with the words,
"here's an aggressive strategy,"
don't open the attachment.
Also, the random capitalization
is a hint that whatever
that person is telling you
is going to be super insane.
It would honestly
look less nutty
if Trump's cronies
just passed notes to each other
with letters cut out
from magazines.
And that wasn't the only text
from an unnamed Republican
lawmaker
essentially proposing a coup.
One text said to Meadows
about the plan for a coup...
Ugh, you never want to hear
the words "tip of the spear."
It's either about an evil plot
or someone's...
-Big Meat.
-And another text...
...to Meadows sent the day after
the insurrection failed, said...
Now, we don't know yet
who exactly sent these texts,
but we do know that
some pro-coup GOP lawmakers
have been super shifty
about their communications
with Trump on that day.
A few months ago,
a reporter asked
Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan
if he talked to Trump
on January 6th,
and he was
extremely cagey about it.
-Yes or no -- Did you speak with
President Trump on January 6th?
-Yeah, I mean, I spoke
with the president last week.
I speak with the president
all the time.
I spoke with him
on January 6th.
I mean, I talked with
President Trump all the time.
I'm actually kind of amazed
sometimes that people
keep asking this ques--
Of course I talk with
the president all the time.
Like I said, I talked
with him last week.
-On January 6th,
did you speak with him before,
during, or after
the Capitol was attacked?
-I'd have to go --
I -- I spoke with him
that day after.
I think after.
I don't know if I spoke with him
in the morning or not,
and I just don't know.
I'd have to go back and --
I mean, I don't -- I don't --
I don't know that -- when
those conversations happened.
-Thank you,
Congressman Nicholas Fehn.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, yikes.
Jordan would have been better
off with
"humina, humina, humina."
[ Chuckles ]
Any time anyone ever talks
that fast about anything,
it's automatically suspicious,
especially in response
to such a
straightforward question.
If you asked your spouse
how work was,
you'd be suspicious
if they said,
"I don't know. How's work?
Work is work.
What's work anyway?
I mean, it was good.
I mean, I don't know.
Work? It's work. It's w--
You know, I'm just amazed
that people
keep asking me this question.
I was at work.
Work is work is work.
It's work."
"Alright, honey, in that case,
I'm going to call
the Property Brothers.
Both of them!"
And yet, despite all of this
incontrovertible evidence,
the text messages,
the secret memos,
all the smoking guns,
we found out about
over the last year,
propagandists in the GOP
and on Fox News are still trying
to rewrite history.
Last night, Fox News contributor
Lara Trump
ludicrously claimed
that Trump tried to warn people
about the insurrection
he himself whipped up.
-These people know --
whether it's Adam Schiff,
whether it's Liz Cheney,
whether it's Kinzinger --
they all know
that Donald Trump
didn't orchestrate
this whole thing.
He didn't tell people to go
to the Capitol and break in.
He said, "let's peacefully
and patriotically
make our voices heard."
But he tried to warn them.
So many people tried
to warn Nancy Pelosi.
So why didn't they have
the adequate security there?
-I'm sorry, what?
Trump tried to warn people
about the coup he fomented?
Do you mean like the way
a serial killer
warns the cops
about his next move?
Did Trump send a fax
to the police
the night before January 6th
with cryptograph
and a zodiac symbol?
Of course,
if Trump ever did that,
he would probably sign
his name to it.
Also, if Trump ever said
the word "patriot,"
he'd inevitably end up
on a long tangent
about how he's best friends
with Tom Brady.
"Tom Brady, we love him.
We love him. Great guy.
Used to be a Patriot.
Now is a Buccaneer.
We love the Buccaneers,
don't we, folks?
But we miss the old helmet.
Oh, we miss the lo--
When he was a pirate
with a tailored mustache
and such beautiful skin.
I always said that's how I'd
look If I wore a fancy hat
and had a knife in my mouth.
I always wondered, why?
Why do you have to
have a knife in your mouth?
I mean, you got to be doing
something pretty important
with your hands if you're going
to put the knife in your mouth.
Are you swinging
from one ship to another?
I don't know.
And we're never --
we're never going to know.
We're never -- 'Cause
they never showed us his body.
Just the head.
It's really -- It's sad.
Where was I? Oh, right.
Burn that [bleep] Capitol
to the ground
and make me president again!"
Anyway, this is our last
"Closer Look" of 2021,
and we have tried to the best
of our ability
to spend this year documenting
all of the evidence
that Trump and his cronies
were very much staging a coup --
from the secret memos
to the newly unearthed
text messages --
and that they're in the process
of doing it again
if they get the chance.
Everyone knew the reality of
what was happening on that day,
even Don Jr. and Fox News hosts,
as we now know
from their private texts.
And yet since then, they've
tried to rewrite history.
I'm sorry, but if you're trying
to tell us now,
nearly a year later that Trump
was actually warning
everyone about the coup
he fomented,
then...
-You are fake news.
-Oh, not the callback clip
you were expecting,
but that's because
it's fake news to suggest
that the insurrection
on January 6th
was just an innocent
little get-together,
and they were all just
hanging out peacefully
at the Capitol for a...
-Big Meat.
[ Laughter ]
There's been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks and
brings over two million meals
a year to men, women and
children living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.